bonjour à tous place dans un instant à
l'audition de bruno racine le directeur
de la bibliothèque nationale de france
qui a été entendue fin mars par la
mission commune d'information sur
l'accès aux documents administratifs et
aux données publiques alors la
numérisation du domaine public doit-elle
rester dans le domaine public bien cette
question fait débat
pour la bibliothèque nationale de france
n'a clairement la réponse est non
puisque la réutilisation commerciale des
données de gallica la bibliothèque
numérique de la bnf et bien et payante
est sujette à licence en effet et bien
cette bibliothèque numérique gallica
rapporte pas moins de cinq cent mille
euros par an à la bnf c'est un choix à
la fois économiques et politiques
pour en savoir plus donc tout de suite
retour à cette audition qui s'est tenu
fin mars au sénat
nous entendons maintenant monsieur bruno
racine
nous avons le plaisir mantes en duo no
racine président de la bibliothèque
nationale de france accompagné de
monsieur arnaud beaufort directeur des
services et des réseaux
monsieur le président l'ouverture des
données culturelles est un enjeu majeur
mais aussi un défi technique et
juridique
pourriez vous nous présenter la
politique de mise à disposition mise en
ligne réutilisation des données
publiques numériques ou des oeuvres
numérisées par la bibliothèque nationale
de france avec les objectifs les publics
visés les jeux de données contenu les
modalités techniques juridiques et
financières de réutilisation décrire les
types de partenariats notamment avec des
acteurs privés
la bnf a développé autour la
numérisation de la mise en ligne d'un
réutilisation enfin nous dire comment
vous envisager les conséquences pour la
bnf de la transposition de la directive
de juin 2013 et des engagements gratuité
prix notamment dans le cadre du g8
ça fait quelques questions monsieur le
président
monsieur le directeur je voulais sa
parole oui merci monsieur le président
je vais essayer de pas être redondant
avec ce que mon ami et le bois n'a pu
dire avant d'en donner les archives je
précise aussi que monsieur beau-frère
qui directeur général adjoint de la bnf
a été aussi le rapporteur de la partie
numérisation demandé par les services de
la culture dans le cas de la
modernisation de l'action publique de
l'amap rapport qui portait sur tout ce
qui est dans le north by two périmètre
c'est la culture
mais non les noms le domaine des
archives
alors pour dans la lettre que vous nous
avez adressé il ya des questions de
disons qu'ils ont portée politique ou
techniques inégal peut-être rappeler que
la bnf dans le domaine de la
numérisation du patrimoine
un matin une expérience assez 11
relativement ancienne puisque sa
bibliothèque numérique gallica a ouvert
la fin du siècle dernier en 98 à la
suite des premiers programmes de
numérisation
gallica avec la politique de
numérisation a changé d'échelle au
milieu de la décennie est passée père
2005 2006 2007
au départ donc numérisation plutôt
sélect très sélective anthologique les
grands textes les les textes
fondamentaux et à la suite notamment de
l'annonce des programmes massifs de
entrepris par google le modèle a changé
et la bnf est passé de ceux de cette
numérisation
je dirais presque artisanale à une
processus industriel de masse notamment
pour les peaux pour les pour les
imprimés et donc nous sommes dans une
succession de programmes de numérisation
de masse imprimés c'est à dire à la fois
les livres et les revues
nous allons rrevient tôt mettre en place
le troisième marché de numérisation de
masse de la bnf marché comme le
précédent d'ailleurs qui sera ouvert je
le dis en passant à hauteur de 30% à des
collections de bibliothèques partenaires
en france paris ou en région à partir de
2008 2009
ce cette entreprise de numérisation de
masse des collections imprimées a été
complétée par une
numéro programme de numérisation plus
méthodique et systématique de ce que
nous appelons dans notre jargon des
collections spécialisées de la bnf
les manuscrits les partitions leccardi
plan estampes gravure photographie
monnaies médailles qu'ils font dans une
très large mesure non seulement la
richesse mais aussi la singularité de
notre patrimoine tandis que des
collections imprimées sont presque par
définition des multiples et donc une
partie d'ailleurs dé se retrouve par
exemple sur sur google books donc ces
programmes forts forment un tout assez
impressionnant maintenant en termes de
quantité puisque sur le gallica nous
avons un peu plus de près de 2 millions
900 mille documents je dirais libres de
droit accessible donc à tous complété ce
n'est pas le tout la numérisation tu
nous avons aussi nuire il y a aussi des
oeuvres sous droits qui sont disponibles
sous forme numérique
elles ne sont pas disponibles à distance
donc elles sont disponibles pour les
lecteurs de la bnf dans ce que nous
appelons gallica intra muros et qui
donne accès
aujourd'hui la différence n'est pas
énorme à où l'on naît entre deux
millions 9 et 3 millions 2 mais au fur
et à mesure que vont se développer des
programmes de numérisation des oeuvres
sous droit notamment dans le cadre de la
loi sur les indisponibles l'écart entre
gallicane intra muros et le gallic à
extra mais rossi je suis dit enfin
légèrement ça va s'accroître de façon
plus significative alors je ne vais pas
peut-être les temps sur le pourquoi de
la numérisation je pense que
tous les domaines concernés ont les
mêmes ont les mêmes ont les mêmes
objectifs
cela étant l'idée de rendre les
collections de la bnf
aujourd'hui réservé aux lecteurs
accrédités ou la guerre réservé aux
seuls électeurs accrédités c'est à dire
1000 à 1300 par jour de les rendre
accessibles à distance s'inscrit aussi
chez nous dans un souci de comme nom
pour les archives les imagine aussi pour
un souci de conservation des documents
ce sens que un certain nombre de
documents très fragile très précieux ne
peut être communiqué qu' avec encore
plus de parcimonie je pense aux
manuscrits à la réserve yvrard donc tout
ce qui est numérisé dans ses collections
et quitte était en réalité accessible
alors là véritablement calé poignée de
spécialistes devient universellement
accessible sans dommage pour les
originaux ce qui est évidemment pour
nous une préoccupation majeure
et puis il ya troisième objectif qui a
un lien avec le sujet libération des
données ou des métadonnées c'est la
réapproprier réappropriation par toutes
sortes de d'utilisateurs des documents
que nous mettons en ligne s'agit pas
simplement de les rendre accessibles
lisible lorca de livres mais aussi d'en
permettre la réutilisation à toutes
sortes de frein
de loisirs culturelles éducatives ou
commerciale bien entrevue éditoriale
notamment donc le la libération des
jeunes des données c'est pour nous un
axe majeur je dirais de notre notre
réflexion et dans lequel il ya lieu je
pense de le distinguer deux sortes de
données celles que nous appelons dans
notre jargon les métadonnées c'est à
dire la description des documents qui
peut être plus ou moins riches et qui en
tout cas métadonnées notice
bibliographique de lui à la salle de
france est en soi réservoir
d'informations et de données
et puis les contenus eux-mêmes les
documents eux mêmes et ce sont deux
problématiques différentes mais
évidemment évidemment lit et vit
évidemment lié alors nous nous vous
demandiez quels étaient les publics
visés
je dirais
s'il n'y a pas de limitation au public
nous visons par cette politique de
numérisation et libération des données
il a évidemment les publics
traditionnels la bnf les chercheurs
notamment où les éditeurs dans le
secteur professionnels qui utilisent
beaucoup qui s'appuie beaucoup sur nos
sur nos données bibliographiques
notamment mais l'idée c'est évidemment
d'élargir ce produit périmètre
relativement anciens et classique aux
enseignants par exemple voire à toutes
les communautés virtuelles qui se
cristallise autour de thèmes ou de deux
thématiques ou de centres d'intérêts
particuliers plus bien entendu c'est je
pense une des préoccupations qui est à
l'oeuvre dans les recommandations de la
2de de l'union de la commission faire de
cette masse considérable de
d'informations et de données culturelles
annalynne en fait un aliment pour la
croissance pour de nouveau les
industries créatives notamment puisque
évidemment plus ces données sont
propriétaires si je puis dire
- elles servent à l'émergence de
nouvelles de nouveaux services ou de
nouvelles
de nouveaux produits marchands alors en
ce qui concerne les métadonnées mais
monsieur beaufort pourrait compléter
beaucoup utilement mon propos la bnf
avec près de combien 13 millions de de
notices biographiques évidemment un des
plus gros réservoir d'information dans
ce domaine
ces données bibliographiques été
conçu selon informa lui même à ses
anciens qui n'est pas spontanément
utilisable ou trouve exploita par là par
les moteurs de recherche donc il ya eu
tout un effort je dois dire massif
accompli par la bibliothèque pour rendre
cette cette masse de données plus
accessible par dans l'esprit de la
libération des mets des métadonnées et
donc ceci c'est se concrétise par un
service particulier qui est apte
le service data bnf point fr lui lui
même lié à la politique d'ensemble de
l'état data.gouv.fr est dans le principe
de data bnf par rapport à un catalogue
classique c'est de réaliser des desclaux
stern et d agrégation de
de données sur un sujet particulier le
sujet peut être un auteur par exemple si
vous avez que sais-je - balzac vous
aurez toutes les oeuvres de balzac sur
une même page n'est ce pas toutes les
oeuvres de balzac sur balzac
les gravures ou les photos de balzac et
ainsi de suite
donc c'est une structuration de ce
réservoir qui est extrêmement
extrêmement riche du coup et qui est
très facilement repérables
compte tenu du format adopté et de cette
richesse même par les moteurs de
recherche
donc alors d'emblée tout ce qui était
sur datta bnf était en licences libres 2
et donc depuis le 1er avril le pôle 1er
janvier de cette année c'est l'ensemble
de nos métadonnées dans seulement data
mais les 12 millions et quelques de ti
dont j'ai parlé qui ont été placées sous
la licence etalab donc je pense que
c'est une contribution c'est assez
massive
dans ce domaine nous avions adopté une
approche similaire
excusez-moi j'ai eu jean un moment donné
si ma voix c'est à ces beaux force
deviendra un atout sont tous points de
vue mon porte parole européen a comme
savait le portail qui donne accès aux
ressources numériques des du continent
européen et european à donges assure
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses la
présidence pour deux ans encore a
demandé à toutes les institutions
contributrice des contenus de placer les
métadonnées sous licence libre sous
licence cc 0 même c'est à dire la plus
la plus ouverte possible permettant
l'imposant pas la mention de sources non
pas parce que nous la juge aurait elle
serait jugée superflue mais parce que
européen n'a pas les moyens d'abord n'y
a pas de sanction et n'a même pas les
moyens de contrôler que des
réutilisations successives mentionne
toujours la source initiale donc toutes
les métadonnées que nous avons fourni à
l'european à son je dirais sous la
licence la plus ouverte possible
lorsque la question s'était posée de
european avidan n'est pas alimentée que
par la bnf au niveau national lorsque la
question s'était posée il ya un an et
deux ans oui de cette ouverture des
métadonnées élue miss à la culture avait
interrogé les différents secteurs
concernés et j'avais pu constater à
cette occasion que tous les domaines
n'avait pas la même attitude si j'ai eu
à l'époque par rapport à cette exigence
donc pour la bnf ou pour lina par
exemple les dires cette libération des
métadonnées ne posait pas de problème
majeur
du côté des musées ou des archives
c'était plus compliqué semble-t-il
notamment du fait que certaines notices
extrêmement le savantes sont plus ou
moins protégés enfin par le couvert par
le parle de parle pour le droit d'auteur
donc leur réutilisation
bon ça c'est un débat évidemment les
biotech pourrait aussi argué que
dans notice on ne sont pas d'une nature
très différente mais bon nous
considérons qu'elles sont faites pour
être pour être mise à disposition donc
jeu on voit bien que ce mouvement
d'ouverture la plus grande possible des
métadonnées et est une tendance de fond
est que à peine de disparaître car
finale mort du fait de la différence que
j'ai mentionnés à ça un nombre non
négligeable de ressources numériques
françaises ont été en quelque sorte
sorti d'europeana faisons mécaniquement
baisser la part des contenus français
dans dans européenne à ce qui est un peu
dommage enfin ça remonte deux depuis
lors alors la question qui vient
immédiatement à l'esprit après la
libération des des métadonnées c'est la
libération des contenus eux-mêmes et
donc la question qui tue que vous posez
par rapport à la directive dont je vais
pas redire tout ce qu'a dit hervé
lemoine la problématique est
fondamentalement n'est pas
fondamentalement différente
nous appliquons
atari fins de réutilisation des
réutilisations des contenus libres de
droits sur gallica et libre dès lors
qu'elle est n est à usage non commercial
ça s'est avancé quand même tout à fait
notable mais pour la perspective qui
était celle de la notamment voulu par
l'union européenne favoriser la
croissance de nouvelles entreprises
innovantes notamment domaine culturel la
barrière s'arrête en fait une barrière
on y va à partir du moment où on passe à
la réutilisation commerciale
donc nous appliquons le tarif enfin une
grille de tarifs
lorsqu'il s'agit par exemple de
reproduire une image donc en face il ya
une licence de réutilisation commerciale
de nos données numérisées qui je crois
respecte l'esprit de la directive c'est
à dire que c'est un peu plus que le coût
marginal
mais néanmoins le ce n'est pas non plus
comme si nous étions une entreprise
privée donc ce seront des tarifs qui
seront votées en conseil
d'administration qui sont transparents
qui sont les mêmes qui sont connus qui
sont les mêmes pour tous je dirais qu'il
n'ya pas de la réalisation commercial
est libre en ce sous licence c'est à
dire que nous ne faisons pas un choix
parmi eux quiconque demande à les
réutiliser
dès lors qu'ils entrent dans le cas de
la licence a le droit de le faire
pas de sélection si je puis dire des
clients potentiels
alors je pourrais aussi compléter mon
propos pas en salissant la numérisation
et des par l'activité de la filiale delà
de la bnf qui est un périmètre assez
restreint mais néanmoins significatif
la filiale la bdf a été créé il y a deux
ans dans le cas du programme
d'investissements d'avenir puisque pour
pouvoir bénéficier
une partie des fonds du fonds pour la
société numérique
l'exil exigences du commissariat général
à l'investissement a été que la bnf se
dote d'une structure dédiée chargé de
porter ces projets donc la filiale su
filiale à 100% de la bnf
elle a conclu deux programmes de deux
accords de numérisation l'un sur le
livre ancien le livre imprimé
avant 1700 l'eau sur ses collections
sonores qui sont en cours d'exécution et
elle s'apprête à prête à conclure
d'autres dont un sur la presse
car dans les collections imprimées dont
j'ai parlé des programmes d'innovation
de masse la presse n'est pas couverte
pour une raison bien après ce soit des
imprimés pourquoi parce que ces marchés
sont là sont financés par une subvention
spéciale du centre national du livre et
que la presse
n'entre pas dans le domaine du du sénat
elle c'est regrettable
par rapport à la cohérence de collection
mais j'allais dire c'est la conséquence
du mode de financement qui était adopté
tant que nous faisons un peu de
numérisation de presse sur l'ocré sur
notre budget propre et nous avons
l'intention de l'accroître
parce que c'est une lacune et de le
compléter par un accord de partenariat
qui d'ailleurs la différence de d'accord
sur le livre ancien kiné touché quand
même que quelques spécialistes capables
de lire des livres en latin du xvième
siècle et donc qu'ils pouvaient
expliquer qu'on adopte pour ce
partenariat des modalités de diffusion
relative temporaire relativement limité
la presse elle intéresse la pluie plus
vaste donc dans le cas des prochains
partenariats que nous envisageons les
collections qui seraient numérisés dans
le cadre de ce partenariat serait
librement accessibles dès la
numérisation et non pas au bout de dix
ans comme c'est dans le cadre de
proquest sauf pour la partie la fraction
que nous mettons en libre accès donc
s'agissant de ces partenariats dont il
repose justement sur un modèle enfin par
définition sur un modèle d'exploitation
commerciale d'offres du domaine public
numérisés
on a maintenant une vision assez claire
de des conditions de l' équilibre qui
sont cohérentes avec les directives
européennes c'est à dire de ne pas
accorder de d'exclusivité même en un
sens limité au delà de au delà de dix
ans et dans certains cas on peut même
atteindre le dépasser le aller au delà
de cette exigence et descendre à 7 ans
il était aussi un souhait de notre part
de limiter au maximum la période
d'indisponibilité pour le grand public
de ces deux de ses collections
donc c'est relativement centré sur sa
faim s'est recentré sur des domaines
très précis mais notamment le cas de la
presse l'impact peut être très fort sur
le grand public gd j'aurais pu lui aussi
sur les collections sonneurs les
collectionneurs sont un cap spécifique
puisque une très grande partie des
collections sonneurs de la bnf qui est
une des plus belles collections au monde
est actuellement quasiment inaccessibles
sont encore supporter j'ai donc là le
modèle est un peu hybride entre le libre
accès et l accès payant mais comme la
diffusion des collections sonneurs dans
le cadre de ce partenariat se fait à
travers de toutes sortes de plateformes
comme youtube deezer etc
une partie de toute manière et en libre
accès selon les modalités
choisie par l'aba par là par la
plateforme voilà peut-être ce que je
pouvais dire jésus
si vous voulez des sur le côté
partenariale peut-être de vous dire si
je dépasse le temps j'en suis témoin qui
parle donc l'ancien phare est fort
simple donc vous ne m'interrompez part
en tout cas le côté partenariale pour le
trouver d'abord dans le jeu jamais dit
un mot déjà dans la numérisation elle
même puisque dans les marchés de masse
mais celui qui va s'ouvrir nous avons
30% de collection provenant d'autres
partenaires dans le cadre de programmes
thématiques ou régionaux thématique ses
parts dans l'histoire de là où le droit
de programmes très important auquel
contribuent d'ailleurs la bibliothèque
du sénat
et comme celle de l'assemblée nationale
ou régionaux c'est notamment là tout ce
qui a trait à la numérisation des revues
des sociétés savantes qui sont une mine
considère régionales locales qui sont
une mine d'informations très importante
au niveau territorial
donc ça c'est un gros bloc si je puis
dire puisque là on parle de 2 millions
de pages numérisées
il y a aussi dans le cadre de la
politique de coopération la bnm venez
vous savez à anima réseau de ce qu'on
appelle les pôles d'associer qui sont
souvent des des bibliothèques
municipales universitaire aussi nous
distribuons sous forme de subventions
environ deux millions par an 2 au titre
des crédits de coopération
principalement pour de la numérisation
la coopération qui était dans le passé
beaucoup une coopération documentaire
d'achat partager à un immigré vers le
numérique
ce soit la conversion des catalogues ou
la numérisation elle même donc au marché
de masse dont j'ai parlé s'ajoute ce qui
peut être numérisés dans le cas de cette
politique de coopération
ce qui fait un ensemble assez assez
important et assure à la fois
garantit à la fois qu' il n'y a pas de
on oublie pas d on ne laisse pas de côté
des lacunes trop importante et qui a une
cohérence qu'on ne duplique pas fait pas
duplication inutile ça c'était l'idée à
la base du schéma national de
numérisation des bibliothèques qui
m'avait été demandé à l'époque pas
madame comme à l'âme albanel était mise
à culture que j'avais remise à son
successeur le partenariat
il est également dans la diffusion alors
puis le gallica est une plateforme de
diffusion donc tout ce qui est numérisé
dans le cas de soi des marchés de masse
soit de coopération est accessible ipso
facto pas par gallica
mais ce n'est pas le seul cas de figure
nous nous par moissonnage des des
métadonnées gallica référence également
des ressources numériques d'autres
bibliothèques dont gallica nez comme la
bibliothèque numérique de la bnf
progressivement devient véritablement
une sorte de bibliothèque numérique de
france
le qui offre un panorama est beaucoup
plus large que les seuls collections de
la bnf
le partenariat s'applique à la
conservation à la préservation pérenne
des données je crois qu'hier mais de
moine a indiqué à quel point cette
question était majeur puisque les deux
des numériques sont par essence fragiles
et périssables et la bnf a développé
grâce au financement du cnl je dois le
dire système star système de
préservation et d'archivage répartir est
parti parce qu'il est pour des raisons
de sécurité sur deux sites et sur
plusieurs supports qui lui permet de non
seulement de conserver ses propres
collections mais offre mais également
d'offrir à des tiers un service de
préservation pérenne alors selon des
modalités qui peuvent varier selon les
choix du partenaire qui vont du simple
stockage à stockage et diffusion par
exemple et puis il y à des innovations
que nous avons est ce que testons enfin
contre mettons en oeuvre plus tôt
maintenant sous faure
une bibliothèque nationale universitaire
de strasbourg qui est le service gallica
marque blanche qui commandite qui permet
aux bibliothèques partenaires d'avoir
leur propre vtec numérique sans avoir
réaliser tous les investissements
techniques ou logiciels nécessaires pour
se faire donc lorsque l'un partenaires
bénéficient du service gallica marque
blanche sa bibliothèque numérique est
entièrement personnalisé à ses couleurs
mais en fait elle est opérée si je puis
l'opérateur invisible s'ils le désirent
et et gallica et c'est un enrichissement
à double sens parce que du coup gallica
référence également les ressources du
partenaire est le partenaire peut
apporter sur sa bible propos
bibliothèque tous ceux qui dans les
collections de la bnf a un intérêt
particulier pour lui par tous les
documents sur l'alsace qui était
numérisées de la bnf qui était sur
gallica peuvent apparaître dans la
bibliothèque strasbourg s'appelle
mistral donc ça c'est une
c'est une expérience extrêmement
significative parce que la biotech de
strasbourg d' extrêmement riche elle a
des effets de son histoire aussi des
particularités en termes de collection
qui font que
une place particulière dans le réseau
des bibliothèques françaises
donc si cette cette offre de marque
blanche apparemment intéresse d'autres
d'autres partenaires parce que ce n'est
pas tout numériser si la diffusion et
éventuellement la conservation ne sont
pas assurés on est dans un travail qui
ne débouchent pas sur grand chose
je pense que c'est un bon exemple de ce
que un grand état binational peut faire
en termes de mutualisation de ces de ces
avancées ou de ses réalisations
d'autant que donc dans le cas de l'autre
intérêt de la marque blanche c'est que
toutes les améliorations constamment
nous cherchons à apporter aux
fonctionnalités de gallica bénéficie à
la bibliothèque du partenaire qui n'a
pas réalisé les développements
correspondant voilà peut-être que je
peux dire un premier temps sur la
libération des contenus néanmoins nous
voyons bien qu'il ya une demande d dire
une autre fuite philosophie si je puis
dire le domaine public dès lors qu'il
est numérisé devrait être en libre accès
enfin livre de réalisation de manière
purement gratuite je dirais c'est n'est
pas pour nous un jeu c'est un choix
politique en réalité
et qui est sous jacent si ce qui n'est
donc pas celui actuellement deux du
gouvernement français ni de ses
établissements publics
il ya un certain nombre de modèles
économiques qui sont évidemment liées au
fait que la réutilisation commerciale de
ces contenus aujourd'hui est payante si
évidemment on passait un modèle de
gratuité ça peut se comprendre dans une
perspective de stimulation de la
croissance de 2,2 d'impulsion donnée aux
industries créatives au monde de
l'édition numérique mais bien introduit
c'est une perte pour les pour les
institutions concernées
dans le cas de la bnf pour donner un
ordre de grandeur
on est deux autour de 5 à ce stade un
demi million de 500000 euros par an au
titre de cette serre de vence pour
exploitation donc c'est pas
négligeable ceni massif dit négligeable
cela étant je sape les croissants et par
exemple nous avions conclu un accord
avec hachette pour l'impression à la
demande des oeuvres de gallica accord
qui sait tenir en réalité en place le
réellement l'année dernière enfin qui a
vraiment commencé à entrer en production
l'année dernière et on voit que la
demande est croissante donc à terme il y
a là un potentiel de recettes tout à
fait tout à fait important
donc il faut voir ceci présent à
l'esprit entre la réalité d'aujourd'hui
est ce que le développement de cette
offre peut donner à court ou moyen terme
voilà monsieur présidence je peux dire
peut-être à porter monsieur le président
ce présent la bnf mes chers collègues
il n'est pas d'usagé d'avoir des
dialogues inter croisés pendant les
auditions donc je vais pas développer
mais je voulais juste préciser que
lorsque cette mission était demandé la
question de la gratuité n'était pas
celle qui était au premier plan c'en est
une mais ça n'était pas celle qui était
structurante dans notre dans notre
raisonnement chez moi j'ai juste de
questions factuelles donc elles ne sont
pas très claires j'ai suivi avec
attention les débats qu'il y avait eu
lieu à l'assemblée nationale voilà sur
ce sujet je voulais juste savoir comment
ça s'était terminé sur la possible ou
non consultation par les collègues
députés du du voile a dû des accords de
partenariat voilà est-ce que vous est ce
que c'est ce qu'ils souhaitaient le
consulter en plus le voir c'était d'une
part sur cette question que j'avais
demandé l'avis de la cada pour savoir
quelle était la règle à suivre donc
la cada nous a donné un avis extrêmement
circonstanciés a dit quand est ce qu'ils
étaient un communiqué et ce qui devait
être biffés donc nous avons mis en ligne
sur notre site les accords
sous réserve du secret industriel et
commercial et à la demande de la
commission de l'assemblée nationale
j'avais transmis au président de la
commission à monsieur cloche pour
consultation les les accords intégraux
tente où je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
été consultés
mais ils étaient consultables à
l'assemblée d'accord donc c'était ma
demande donc les choses ont peut être
fait pour le voilà donc c'était ma
deuxième demande si ça a été fait pour
l'assemblée trois encaissés lors des
deux précédents s'appelait voilà je vous
remercie
pour ma part je voudrais laisser la
parole donc vous remercier d'être venu
et laisser la parole à mes collègues
s'ils ont des questions merci d'avoir
été aussi précis dans vos réponses aux
travaux merci monsieur juste pour
rapport à la remarque de douche ou effet
la gratuité des tvg bien compris la
question est ce que la direccte
l'application de la directive un
incident sur tout tarif là la réponse
est non parce que nous les avions par
anticipation si j'ose dire
conçu dans l'esprit de cette directive
je remercie vous savez ça mieux que moi
la question de la gratuité dans le cadre
du g8 est quelque chose qui dépasse et
de loin la compétence de cette modeste
commission voilà pour l'audition de
bruno racine le directeur de la
bibliothèque nationale de france
vous l'avez vu outre le sujet de gallica
un sujet qui prête à débat et bien la
bibliothèque nationale de france mène
une politique extrêmement importante en
matière de numérisation des données et
d'ouverture des données publiques
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site sur publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire et bien à 19h pour 24
heures 5 présenté par delphine girard
très bonne après midi sur la chaîne
parlementaire